so as I'm trying to clinch you can find
that bicep tie real quick you see and
it's hard for me to get something okay
now he can use his head to control me
says I can't really go under him you see
okay but I'm not going to sit here like
this okay I touch whatever I can touch
okay and as as he's driving and he's
trying to keep that foot underneath his
head so right here I
can't get that all time and do anything
with it cuz his leg's
there so I pay attention to the Rhythm
that he's going you see
there so I'm in the rhythm is one two I
go for it okay if if I can get it then
I'm going to get
it and he's going to counter that which
I'm
expecting Okay so I go foed and now I
can attack the
head cuz the leg's Not underneath it
anymore so
[Music]
again it's very much like
this I'm going to fake over here and
he's going to guard over there like this
so I do that it's
this okay same thing here here I I move
the
leg and I'm looking for
that okay let's
go when when you go for this leg drag
don't just drag his balance and make him
step con connect with everything connect
with everything
everything connects his whole body then
you're going to get the step okay so not
here yeah a lot of people will step but
not everyone so I get his whole body
step when I want the other side same
thing don't pull down cuz even fewer
people will step cuz you'll pin that leg
so you have to move the whole body the
whole body has to move okay so then
you'll get that foot to a step all right
try it
okay so I'm going to move him fake he's
going to counter
who nothing you got to get his height
out of
there okay let's
go that's the one you bringing that leg
forward so you can get it okay so he has
to counter it just this
one
step smooth it
out smooth it out let's good
[Music]
now you now you work the other side work
the other
side down
so his front leg this time make sure
don't just pull get the whole body so
that step goes then that leg's right
there heel def Bend and
that's you have to make a serious
threat on this
[Music]
movement okay let's go
so don't hold down going to pin the leg
you see then your athleticism has to
bring right instead I hold the whole of
your body the whole of your body you
think and the whole body
mov the
whole hold
P try